the silence is held every year at 11AM
on the 11th of November to remember
those who lost their lives it's also a
chance to remember those who have died
in conflict in the 100 years since
let's go to our Midlands correspondent
now Lisa Dowd who's at the National
Memorial Arboretum in Staffordshire Lisa
or veterans families and Military
figures have all gathered here at the
National Memorial Arboretum to Mark the
end of world war one but of also to
remember these service men and women who
have given their lives in service for
their country over the decades and of
course this is the first Armistice Day
since the passing of the late Queen
Elizabeth II she will of course be in
people's thoughts here today as well and
she was a patron of this National
Memorial Arboretum and of course was
commander-in-chief of the Armed Forces
for such a long time so there will be a
poem read out in her memory written by
The Poet Laureate Simon Armitage today
and the will of course be a two-minute
silence observed here as it will be
Across the Nation and there will be a
wreath-laying ceremony as well
Lisa thank you well as we approach 11
o'clock this is the scene now people
will soon pause across the country and
fall silent for two minutes to Mark
Armistice Day
and that is the scene at the senator
from the National Memorial Arboretum in
Staffordshire to the cenotaph in Belfast
to the fields of Remembrance in
Westminster and Cardiff people across
the country falling silent
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
when you go home tell them
we gave R today
hahaha
[Music]
right
and a single bugler there marking ravali
that bugle call that marks the end of
that two-minute silence rivalry of
course a call that signals the start of
the day's activities of any soldier's
life it's one of a number of bugle calls
in military tradition that marks the
phases of the day and here we have
wreaths being laid after that two-minute
silence observed Across the Nation
to Mark the anniversary of the end of
World War One In 1918.
remembering not only those who lost
their lives in that conflict but in the
100 years since and this year's
commemorations of course
beginning
with recently restored Big Ben striking
11 times
it is a two-minute silence that is held
every year
at the 11th Hour
of the 11th day of the 11th month
to Mark the end of that Great War
Remembrance Day services
will be held on Sunday
the Royal Family
attending one at the senator of the
first since the death of the queen
you're looking at pictures of the
National Memorial
Arboretum where our Midlands
correspondent Lisa Dowd is at the moment
let's speak to Lisa now and how are they
marking the day there Lisa
well I've been speaking to some of the
people who are gathered here and on some
of their minds as well as the fact that
war in Europe is again being waged and
they've talked about how some of the
scenes there have been reminiscent of
conflicts passed though that very much
on their mind as well the service here
will conclude with God Save the King
King Charles who of course is now the
new commander of the Armed Forces and
there is Royal representation here in
the figures of the Duke and Duchess of
Gloucester who will be completing the
planting of 26 trees following the
service in memory of the late Queen
Elizabeth II the former
commander-in-chief of the Armed Forces
as a part of a nationwide project to
commemorate her with the planting of a
million trees and once this service has
concluded people will have time to
reflect on this Memorial there are the
names of 16
000 service men and women etched into
the Portland Stone they are service men
and women who have been killed since
World War II and a sobering thought that
there is room on this memorial for the
names of 15
000 more
okay Lisa thank you very much
our ceremonies continue and they would
of course continue throughout this
weekend as it is the 11th of November
today we have La we have just marked two
minutes silence to Mark Armistice Day
the end of world war one back in 1918
and to commemorate
those we have lost not only in that war
but in every war since